the following recording is an interview
between doctor and SCP 457 currently yes
good would you mind answering some
questions I'll take that as a no how do
you feel about being confined dislike no
fuel no air we provided you with
adequate air and fuel to survive how do
you feel do you feel anything besides
hunger how do you feel about humans
please move away from the window or we
will be forced to reduce your size
considerably how do you feel about water
please move away from the window or we
will be forced to turn the sprinklers
back on you understand that stay away
from the window and you will not be
doused
do you understand
there is no way out at this point in the
interview the CP 457 managed to severely
damage much of the sprinkler system and
destroy a portion of the fuel injector
that had been sustaining its intelligent
form giving it free access to several
gallons of gasoline the video portion
was destroyed but the audio from this
interview was taken from the security
tapes recovered from the blast a CP 457
temporary breach of containment came
from an exploitation of the sealant used
to attach the blast shielding to the
rest of the chamber power CP 457 managed
to learn of and exploit this weakness is
unknown and it has since been moved to a
higher security chamber
you